[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Eyes on Enterprise.
I'm Stephanie Wong,
and today we're
talking with Brian Dorsey,
Developer Advocate for Compute.
And we're going to
be talking about how
to approach cloud
infrastructure for enterprises
and how to decide where
to deploy your workloads.
We have a multitude of
options on Google Cloud.
And so it can be a
challenge to optimize
for things like scalability,
performance, developer
experience.
So Brian, thanks so
much for being here.
BRIAN DORSEY: Thanks
so much for having me.
This is one of my favorite
topics, so I'm really excited.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's great to hear.
So first off, there
are lots of options
on Compute, Compute Engine,
App Engine, and Cloud Run.
And enterprises, they have
a lot of legacy systems
and a lot of dependencies in
place like message brokers,
databases, web apps.
So through the lens
of an enterprise,
how should they make
that initial decision?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
Yeah.
It gets complicated.
We have a lot of
different options
and enterprises are
complicated things.
So I think--
I like to think about it as
kind of an abstraction, kind
of a layer cake almost,
where at the bottom
you have things
like VMs, and then
you kind of move up and
up in layers as you go.
So you've got things
like Kubernetes,
or Cloud Run, App
Engine functions,
and they get more
abstract as you
get kind of closer to the top.
And I think enterprises,
also they're big, right?
So you end up often running
multiples of those things
together to solve the
same-- in the same system.
STEPHANIE WONG: To be honest,
I think a lot of enterprises
face this challenge of
feeling like they're
going to make the
wrong decision and they
need to make the right
decision from the get-go.
So how do you help them make
that choice to dive in and not
feel like they have
wasted time and resources
investing in the wrong
infrastructure option?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
That can be really scary, right?
You know, like all
this effort and if you
have to change things later.
So I think there's a
few things we can do.
You can kind of try
to lower the risk,
and there's some technical
things we can do that.
I think running
software in containers
really helps with that.
Nearly all of our
computer environments
support running software
that's running in containers.
I think that's true for most
of the other environments
people might be using.
So I think that helps a lot.
Also, you can just decide
not to move it, right?
You know, you've got
[INAUDIBLE] existing systems.
Maybe, you know--
I think one of my favorite
definitions of enterprise
is where most of the software
doesn't have an engineering
team on it at all.
You know it needs
to keep running.
It needs to work.
But it's the ops folks who are
like trying to keep that going.
And there I think VMs
are really useful.
And once you have some of your
software running in cloud,
you're trying to make a
bigger system out of it.
So you started trying
to glue it together.
And I think that's where
serverless and things like
that can help.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
Wait.
Hold on.
Serverless.
So everyone has a different
definition of serverless.
Even at Google, we
have varying products
under the serverless ecosystem.
So help us define what
that is here in this case.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm
not going to do it.
Like, there's so many
definitions as serverless.
I think it's a little tricky.
But for the purpose
of this conversation,
let's focus on that kind of
pay-for-use, like the actual--
you do some work and you
pay for only that work.
I think that's the core
definition of serverless.
And I think it will help
in this conversation.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I mean, wouldn't you argue that
that pay-for-use model applies
to Compute Engine, too, though?
BRIAN DORSEY: Kind of.
So when we're
talking pay-for-use,
we're thinking of the
actual work being done.
And Compute Engine, and our
VMs, and several other things
in cloud, you're
kind of reserved--
you're paying while
it's on, virtually.
So you're paying
for the reservation.
And you might not be getting
any value out of that.
You might just be
sitting there idle.
So there are things you
can do to minimize that
and you want to do that.
But the serverless
stuff is designed
so you're only paying for
the actual work being done.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: You know, give
an HTTP request, or responding
to a message broker,
or something like that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
So it's more event driven.
You have the potential to scale
down to zero, things like that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
OK.
So let's just talk about these
abstraction layers in order,
if you don't mind
going through them.
BRIAN DORSEY: Totally.
You have kind of
functions as a service,
and I think there
is Cloud Functions.
And you know, from
a developer-- this
is a developer tool primarily.
From the developer's
perspective,
you write this like small
piece of code, a function,
and you kind of push
it up to Google Cloud.
And we do all of the
work of running it.
It responds to an event,
like you said earlier,
or that might be
something coming from HTTP
or from a message system.
Does a little bit of work,
maybe a side effect, maybe not,
and then returns.
That's it.
STEPHANIE WONG: So what
makes serverless a good fit?
And when would it
be something that's
more of a constraint for people?
BRIAN DORSEY: So it's showing
up in lots and lots of spaces.
So I think people are
exploring all the use cases.
So consider that.
But some of the places
that are especially strong
is in kind of gluing
systems together,
where you've got a bunch
of existing pieces.
And you're trying
to make them all
behave like they're one system.
And also in a lot of,
kind of, message flow kind
of scenarios where people
are doing either data
transformations, or
they're moving information
from one system to another.
Things like that is
where it shows up
the most for this level
of the abstraction, that
function side.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right, and
then besides Cloud Functions
and Cloud Run, we also have
our longtime managed service
from 2007, App Engine.
And that's been great
for developing web
applications and the like.
So can you explain
what App Engine is
and what it's used
for specifically?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah
so App Engine,
it's a wider view of the code.
You have a full code base.
It's still a code-focused
kind of environment.
And you push that
whole code base.
It's really meant for
hosting web apps primarily.
And so you have
the different URLs
respond to to and the different
code that handles that.
And it works as one piece.
So you've got the code,
hosted database pieces,
and the same kind of idea.
You have an app, you
push it to Google,
it runs it, scales
it up and down.
It's really good for things
where it's really bursty,
where you can't really
plan for the usage,
and you need to be able
to respond, but also
not have a bunch
of infrastructure
sitting there idle when
you're not using it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right,
and I can imagine
with retail online
shops that are expecting
huge, bursting events like
Black Friday, things like that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly that.
STEPHANIE WONG: All
right, so working our way
down the abstraction layer
cake, we have Cloud Run.
Can you tell me
about what that is?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
So it's kind of trying
to make the combination
of the containers world
and the serverless world,
and give you kind
of the best of both.
So from the container
side, it lets
you run any software that
will run in a container
and can listen to a web
request, HTTP request, or events
coming that same
way, and serverless.
You get to pay for what you
use, and only what you use.
You get this hosted environment
to run anything you want,
basically.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
Cloud Run, yeah.
It seems like it's something
that developers have been
rallying for for a while now.
They want the portability and
the flexibility of containers,
but they also want the agility
that serverless gives them.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
STEPHANIE WONG: So we've
mentioned containers
a bunch of times already.
What is it exactly?
Let's talk about that.
BRIAN DORSEY: So from
a technical standpoint,
there's a bunch of
things you could say.
We're usually talking
about Docker containers.
Under the covers,
they're really, actually,
a [INAUDIBLE],, a ZIP
file of some files.
Practically, though, I think
what it does is it solves the--
works on "my machine"
problem, like where
something worked
in one environment,
but doesn't in another.
That worked on my machine.
Like, so it just makes
things much more consistent
wherever you're running them.
I think that's the key
takeaway for containers.
STEPHANIE WONG: So for
those that are already
running a large
number of containers,
what would you recommend
them to deploy on?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
I mean I think
that's what Kubernetes
was invented to help with.
So it's basically a
service, a system,
a set of tools, open source
environment for running lots
of containers across
lots of machines,
but with the idea of treating--
instead of thinking about
individual containers,
we're thinking about
individual computers.
You're thinking about the
application as a whole,
or like microservices as
you mentioned earlier,
and how they fit together,
and how the pieces talk
to each other, and managing
all of that communication
as well as the
containers themselves,
and insulating you from the
actual, physical or virtual
hardware they're running on.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
So that brings us to GKE,
or Google Kubernetes Engine.
Tell us more about
what that is used for.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Yeah, so Kubernetes
is an open source project.
And it helps that this runs in
a lot of different environments.
And Google Kubernetes Engine
is taking the expertise
that Google engineers and
SREs built, building this up
and the longtime experience
of running software at Google
to make a hosted
version of Kubernetes,
where we handle the
upgrades to the software,
keeping the masters
online, things
like that, and basically, let
you focus on the application
even more than you would.
And under the covers,
it's running on VMs
and the rest of Google Cloud.
But you don't have
to worry about that.
It's just kind of all handled.
It's up.
If you want to make
it larger or smaller,
there's knobs you can turn
to do that sort of thing.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Is there any kind
of opportunity for
those that are running
their workloads on App Engine to
move over to Kubernetes Engine,
for example?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And in fact, basically all
up and down this stack,
most of the
environments allow you
to run software in containers.
So that's true from App
Engine, Cloud Run, Kubernetes,
and VM's compute engine
we talk about in a minute.
So once you get
into a container,
you can move things
around pretty smoothly.
STEPHANIE WONG: All
right, so on GKE,
what are good use
cases for, and what
are some of the constraints?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, so it
makes this insulation layer.
So that is a good
example, so if you
need to run the same application
in multiple different
environments.
So this comes up, for
like dev and test and prod
for almost everybody.
But you can also see it come
up for writing game servers,
for example.
You need to build to run in
different legal environments.
We're talking
enterprises here, right?
And large companies have
legal-specific policies.
They have teams that are
responsible for different parts
of the systems.
You need to be able
to plug your system
into the other things
that are already
going on the enterprise.
And Kubernetes is
especially good at that.
It's really modular.
And you can connect your
different enterprise pieces
into every level,
from authentication
to policy about firewalls, all
the way up and down the stacks,
and get the different
teams who are
responsible for those
involved in working
at it at the Kubernetes level.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
and just for performance
and also just optimization
for utilization
of your compute resources,
how does it affect that?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
so the utilization
is the key phrase there.
That's the reason everybody
cares about containers at all,
so you can run more software
on the same machines.
STEPHANIE WONG: Exactly.
BRIAN DORSEY: And that's
what containers are for,
and honestly why
Google cared about it.
You get more running
on same hardware.
And the same thing is
true in cloud as a whole.
In cloud, utilization
usage costs money.
So if you can optimize
there, it saves you money
and hopefully time as well.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, so
we just talked about GKE
and some of the
performance and cost
optimizations that
you get with it.
But, I mean, I want to talk a
little bit about that low level
of abstraction, Compute Engine.
It gives you a lot
of flexibility.
You can take care of
everything that you
deploy on the VM, like
software and any installations
that you have on it.
So when does it actually
makes sense for you
to choose Compute Engine?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, so this is--
it's one of my favorite services
because it underlies so much
of the rest of cloud.
For one, GKE is,
in turn, running
on top of Compute Engine.
Our managed databases are.
And I think that's especially
relevant for enterprises
because you have
so much software
that doesn't have an
engineering team on it, right?
You need to keep it working.
And almost always, the best
first step for that is to--
it may already be
running in a VM,
and if not, to move it into a
VM or move it into a Cloud VM.
And you can usually do that.
It's flexible enough,
you can usually
do that without having to change
hardly anything because it
is a computer.
It's a virtualized machine.
So you can run the
same things you've
been running other places.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
you mentioned software
that needs to run without a
developer team supporting it
necessarily all the time.
So give me some examples there,
like any stories that you have.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, yeah.
I mean, I think this is like
classic enterprise, right?
You know, you've got--
you've got the team
that builds it.
And then they have to move
on and build the next thing
and build the next thing
and build the next thing.
So even in-house
software tends to not
have active engineering on it.
But also you're
buying or renting
software from other
places that needs
to work third party software
you have to keep running.
And then there may just be
some old stuff where you don't
know the history of it at all.
There's that thing that
nobody quite knows how to redo
but needs to keep working.
And all of those, I think, are
a good fit for running on VMs.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
Yeah, I think we've all
have been in that case
where we're working
with software,
but the code base is so old.
It takes so long
to make changes.
And maybe it's not the
best fit for deploying
in a containerized
environment right now.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
so for anything
where it's not the right time
to kind of make changes to it,
the VMs are a good
place to start.
STEPHANIE WONG: So we just went
through the abstraction layer
cake, as you mentioned.
And there are a ton of
options we just covered.
So, once again, to kind of
wrap our heads around this,
how do you make that decision?
BRIAN DORSEY: Part of it
is just this abstraction,
like how do you want to
be working as a team?
And if your team is
mostly developers,
that's going to keep you kind
of higher at the abstraction.
If you're mostly kind of
ops or have deep integration
requirements or
existing things, you're
mostly going to be
on the lower levels.
There's also some
technical constraints.
It's worth checking
the docs to make sure
that these specific
things you need
are available in each
of the environment.
And then I kind of
mentioned team a little bit.
But I just want to
double down on that.
What is your team
most comfortable with?
What do you care about the most?
What do you need to do
and want to do as a team?
And I think that may also
kind of affect things there.
The other piece is
maybe not so obvious
is just where in
the lifecycle it is.
For things that are newer, you
have the full range of options.
And I encourage people to start
high on the abstraction thing
and go down if you need to.
For existing systems,
you're usually
going to be working your way
up from other VMs or containers
kind of from the bottom.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
All right, so we
talked about so much.
But what can people
do to actually
get started on some of these?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
I think, yeah, there
are a lot of options.
And I think if specific
ones of these jumped out,
and you're like, oh,
that's what I need, go dig
into that a little bit.
Look at the docs,
we have code labs
on each of these for what it
feels like to actually use
and get started on.
If you want a bit
more information,
I did a much longer
talk on the same topic.
And you can take a look at
that and kind of go from there.
But yeah, give it a try.
Think about how this works
for your applications,
and what your challenges are,
and where adding some of this
in is going to really help out.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, I
think the important point
that you made earlier
was you don't actually
have to move all your
stuff to the cloud.
You can pick and choose the
ones that make sense and then
think about which
layer of abstraction
makes the most sense for
your development teams.
All right, Brian.
Thank you so much for
being on the show.
I encourage everyone
to check out
Brian's talk where he dives
in much deeper about some
of these topics.
And again, join us next
time for Eyes on Enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]